[Music]
foreign
[Music]
up in DC obviously
you know it's like growing up growing up
in in Hollywood with the movie business
you know my family had nothing to do
with politics but it's sort of
unavoidable when you grow up there and I
remember you know growing up I I became
enormously close with um with Theresa
Bradley Bill Bradley's daughter and uh
you know I just thought he was the
coolest dude in the world because he was
so tall you know and he took me to a
Knicks game once he's a good ball player
you know what I'm saying like Spike Lee
came over and said what's up that was
crazy you know what I mean and uh you
know but I remember when he was running
for president uh I remember he he said
succinctly to to to Teresa you know
whether I win or lose here it's totally
dependent on whether I followed my North
Star of being truly authentic to myself
whether I didn't violate my own beliefs
to try to Garner a vote to try to get
something and you know to me when I look
at leaders when I look at people that I
would follow anywhere it to me it's it's
folks that I've experienced things with
it's folks and and for me I I need to be
in the box with that person I need to
see I've read I've read your work I'm so
taken with you I'm so taken with what
you're about and the things that you've
done
one like what's your North Star you know
what who is your authentic self but two
what do you say to people who just
believe politicians by Nature
are fluid and are changing and are part
of a a divisive uh kind of structure in
this country that's completely corrosive
yeah
um that's a long-ass question I
apologize
I'm doing the best I can man you know I
mean I really it's a lot of questions in
one but I'm genuinely I'm loving this
okay
um
you know I I would say um
you know first in in when I think about
my North Star it's just authenticity I
remember having this conversation in
fact I was having this conversation with
Dougie when uh as we first first got on
board I said listen I have no problem
spending all day long introducing myself
to people who don't know me
I won't spend a second of a day
reintroducing myself to people who do
I am who I am
and I never want a situation where
people who are like I thought I knew Wes
but now that he's going into politics
I'm seeing a different person right I'm
hearing different issues I'm like nah
like everything we're talking about
these are issues we've been working on
from a whole adult life and I am who I
am you know what I mean and so I think
authenticity and being able to move with
a sense of urgency does become important
I think it's the same thing where you
know you think about you know uh someone
actually was actually saying the uh the
other day when they were reading The
Works whether it's the other Westmore or
the work et cetera they're like I feel
like I'm already getting a sense of your
platform because you told us a decade
ago about what matters and what kind of
stuff you care about right and for the
people who feel frustrated about the
system I guess my answer is I hear you
and it's Justified for so many of us our
lives
and what's happened in our lives don't
give us a reason to believe
that this thing can change my
grandfather was the first one in my
mom's side of the family born in this
country
and his father my great-grandfather was
a minister and he was a vocal Minister
like one of these dudes it was like I'm
not just going to teach you the word I'm
gonna I'm gonna ask you to live it here
on Earth
um and eventually started getting
threats
and eventually the Ku Klux Klan uh
started making physical threats in his
family in the middle of the night he
picked up his family to include my
grandfather and moved and so the Ku Klux
Klan ran them out and it wasn't just ran
them out of the community they ran him
out of the country he literally they
went to Jamaica
and um and from most of my family for
much of my side of family they never and
they always vowed to never come back to
this country and they didn't they stayed
in Jamaica so that's why you know I'm a
proud he already has still got a lot of
family down down in Jamaica but my
grandfather
didn't my grandfather and I always say
in all of his humility said this country
would be incomplete without me and he
came back here he went to an HBCU he
eventually became a minister like his
father
um he became the first black minister in
the history of the Dutch Reformed Church
and I always say this is a man who he
died at 87 he died when I was in
Afghanistan
and he had a deep Jamaican accent his
entire life
and was maybe the most patriotic
American I've ever met wow he loved this
country he loved this nation with his
deep Jamaican accent and
I think about him often on this idea
where when people have a sense of
frustration that things can change or
whatever like that like I hear them
and I can't question their feeling about
it because the truth is is that this
journey this this route it's been
remarkable and has been uneven
um but I also know that when I think
about like my grandfather
a person who just believes so deeply in
what this nation hoped to be
daddy believes so deeply in the idea of
community that with each passing time in
each passing moment we actually could be
better and I think about now that that
man's grandson
is on the cusp of becoming
the first black governor in the history
of a state
I can't give up
I can't give in like I've seen I've seen
the breakage and I've seen the
rebuilding yep and so the thing that
keeps me going is I know what's real but
it's only real if we will it it ain't
gonna happen because of inevitability
you know it ain't gonna happen because
we show up that's right you got to work
and I just choose not to curl up in a
fetal position
I choose to work because I've seen what
can happen uh if we do because I had
examples that I came up with that showed
me that sure talk a little bit about
Maryland because you you started this by
saying uh you're a proud marylander you
love this state we both grew up here
we're not the best known state in the
country so not everybody knows what
makes Maryland great what do you love
about Maryland like when you think about
it what do you tell people about this
state I I love the fact that you know
and and for all those non-marylands out
there you know for our for us
marylanders you know Maryland is known
as American miniature right where within
a two three hour basis you can go from
the hills and the mountains you can go
mountain climbing to the beach
that you can go from skyscrapers to
Farmland it's literally anything that
you want in the country you're going to
be able to see and get all kinds of
people and all kinds of people and I
love that about the state right I love
the diversity of the state I love the
fact that you know I could sit there and
have you know in the morning have
conversations with crab Pickers
and then later on have conversations
with you know with attorneys and doctors
and then later on turn around and have
conversations with someone who's
recently released who's now coming home
to someone who has been a you know been
working at a paper mill has just gone
I've gone out of business now trying to
figure out what they're going to do
because their whole town just lost their
largest industry like I love the fact I
can have all these various conversations
in one day one day in the state of
Maryland
um and and I think about all the assets
that we have here in the state of
Maryland we always say you know the
state of Maryland this is literally the
home of everything from the Port of
Baltimore to to you know the Chesapeake
Bay to the NIH and the CDC to NASA to
you know for the top hbcus historic
black college universities in this
country like we've got so much here but
we are asset rich and strategy poor
where we have all these assets here and
it's amazing how arbitrary and miserly
we are about who can actually benefit
from those assets and how we leverage
those assets and so one of the things
I'm really excited about is
both creating a society you know we have
on our campaign what we call you know
the leave no one behind agenda
and that actually came from the military
where you know I first you know joined
when I was 17 uh and you know a mantra
they asked us to live by when I first
joined the military was leave no one
behind every Mission will be evaluated
on that leave no one behind and that is
the philosophy that I want the state of
Maryland to say come January we will be
a state that leaves no one behind
because we don't have to and but the
whole basis of the leave no one behind
agenda is as a state we are going to
grow as a state we are going to compete
as a state we're going to win as a state
we are going to recruit I'm going to
take the state on the eight-year Road
show I want to show the country that
this is where you want to be
but we will leave no one behind in the
process
and that's that's that's the vision and
that's the mission
[Music]
foreign
[Music]